hello and welcome to this video Kaaba in
the house and I've got something new
against him
we've played tons of gasquatch games and
I think also some Sicilians so let's see
what he does here
amazing many players really commit this
mistake with the c-4 which it really is
a mistake ok so we'll see I had this in
the livestream but in that livestream I
did not fully punish it any mistake it
is a mistake it's probably the right
word not not like losing mistake but
leading to a good game for black mistake
because if I'm is weak the bishop on g2
is sucks maybe I can even punish this
hard and work with them on with age 65
things instead of what I'm doing here
Nayla I'm ok but it doesn't feel like
real punishment
a bishop g5f 4 is an idea if I get 2
then I'm probably winning the ball okay
yeah I cannot and it's no tactic here
based on the weaknesses 95 to d3 and
things like that so doesn't do a welcome
go Queen G form again I can still do
that I mean it's interesting queen g4
and then I am Bishop d2 actually this is
an interesting move the rook on the look
then has to here the rook has to go to
f1 done yet rookie to Bishop c3 I'll
just win because of this big back rank
and look everyone I can kick that corner
so I'm winning the pawn yes if it lets
electrons defense sometimes you you win
it's just win a big center pawn
okay so he decides to instead give the
other material but I have this and still
can take on e5 and now take on each side
there is nothing particularly wrong with
it at least I don't see maybe the other
one I don't know but that should make a
difference no doesn't it doesn't make a
difference
can wrap this and now we are Knight f4
actually forces them to take and that's
that that's it basically there are no
pins or whatnot so it's just a clean
exchange plus the pollution of advantage
chicken take probably on yeah yeah it's
the cleanest way I think you look the -
I guess he's got Luke g4 but I just have
g6 so doesn't really threaten all that
much okay
okay so I guess g6 and there's 91
actually no there isn't one of course
not a knight is pinned I mean I saw that
94 doesn't work 91 is the same thing of
course
yeah so just look checks Queen f2h three
mate
nice it's just so long
now it's a bit too late now okay
quite there is nothing yeah the other
hand opening opening disaster yeah so I
think that switch is on I think that c4
is a strategic mistake in this position
I mean the it just just doesn't help
yeah you know white weakens d4 and here
on ya ropes himself of this possibility
to support the pawn and I got all kinds
of things yet again c5 gone and it's
nothing it doesn't really it doesn't
really AM yeah feel right at least this
is my take on the position that term and
Sonia and the engine wants to play
Bishop h5 i preparing f4 of course let's
say that you can do over there for but
that also weakens the position a bit I
mean this is probably better than what
he did them so here Bishop b4 yeah that
makes sense again trying to make f4 a
possibility a little bit surprised at
what should be better here it okay
taking at 94 that's interesting that's
interesting
so maybe Bishop g5 wasn't all that good
now maybe I mean yeah everything worked
to absolute perfection
yeah each one okay and 95 I didn't see
that that's a that's a move I mean this
wins immediately and here I'm also
winning a big bone and so better in this
air you just get checked
completely completely killed yeah it's a
tricky opening this Alekhine's defense
and most people don't have
specific knowledge and without specific
knowledge white doesn't get all that
much okay guys thanks for watching